But you said it was okay to take vitamin C supplement. Yes. Can I take para-clair with
Ben- Benzol? Yes, you can. Yep. Doing the same work if you're taking Ben- Benzol for
parasites, can you take para-clair? Yes, it's working on- if Ben- Benzol is a medication
to kill parasites, para-clair is an herbal combination to kill parasites. You're doing
the same thing. Do you need to do both? No. You could try one or the other. If
you're taking Ben- Benzol for cancer, totally different thing. So when you're
taking Ben- Benzol for cancer, you're not trying to kill parasites. You might kill
parasites while doing it because it is going to work on parasites if you have
parasites. So just so just so you'll understand. I'm taking four parasites. Okay, well
you can take para-clair with it. Certainly can. There's nothing wrong with it. You
won't hurt yourself by doing that. And you won't hurt yourself by taking vitamin C
with it either. Vitamin C really isn't the greatest parasite killer, but it's
certainly IV vitamin C. Taking oral vitamin C can work with your gut a little bit
more. IV vitamin C I would use that for parasites.